[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy inauguration day
it's a big moment for the country
the changing of the guard a peaceful
transfer of power
another reassuring display of the
awesome pageantry of constitutional
government
there were solemn speeches today sworn
oaths belted
anthems all echoing against the backdrop
of 26 000 smartly attired federal troops
who were guarding our capital city from
unseen threats was quite a display
it was all a lot to take really so like
many of you we flipped on the tube
to see what it meant and here's what we
learned
joe biden respects government he
respects people who disagree with him he
listens to them
i think that joe biden is going to train
us to see the world differently he plans
to usher in a new era of hope
and the action he's promising the minute
he takes office we've gone from
indecency to decency he filled that
empathy void there was not one part of
that that wasn't just
medicine in the world those lights that
are that are
just shooting out from the lincoln
memorial along the reflecting pool
i look it's like almost extensions of
joe biden's arms
embracing america it was a moment
where the new president came to town
so to recap joe biden respects people's
differences but at the same time he's
going to
train us to be very different from the
way we are he will bring
hope and decency he will feel the
yawning void where our empathy should be
he is medicine joe biden's arms lean and
hard from decades of empathetic labor on
our behalf
will encircle us like lights from the
lincoln memorial and at that point
well god knows anything is possible if
there's a thin bead of sweat forming on
your upper lip as you think about all of
this that's okay
don't feel shame shame isn't necessary
now joe biden is here
and not just joe biden jill biden too
mrs biden
dr biden together the two of them msnbc
informed us
will redeem this nation through their
love
behold what a story though what a great
love story between
jill biden and joe biden it's just a
different
kind of marriage this is a love match
like the obamas were so i think that'll
be healing for the country too
the biden's marriage is healing for all
of us
for the country the biden's love is
america's love
jill and joe are the mother and father
of this nation from their loins we are
born and yet reborn
may their names emerge from our lips in
praise forever
and so on that was cable news today the
funny thing is and there are many funny
things going on right now
every person with the microphone in
every tv studio in america today
knew the fuller truth when they said
things like the ones you just heard
they knew for example for certain that
joe biden isn't well
everyone in washington knows that but no
one said it out loud not a word they
withheld that news from you as they have
for months
so much for speaking truth to power on
the other hand
what did you expect you've watched the
lying for years now you know what it is
you figured out how it works
so it dawned on us today that maybe we
ought to stop playing all these stupid
media clips every night
it's like watching the town drunk throw
up on himself over and over again
obviously it's repulsive and shocking
it's hard to turn away
but can you really be surprised by it
throwing up on themselves
is what town drunks do if you keep
watching them as they do it maybe after
a while you are part of the problem
maybe so any case we flipped off cnn and
decided to check out joe biden's speech
for ourselves and it was interesting
actually both for what it said
and for what it didn't say one
particular part of this speech stuck out
especially
now we didn't support joe biden for
president you probably guessed that
but if we're being totally honest here
and we want to be honest we have to say
it was very hard to disagree with this
specific part of the address
watch on this january day my whole soul
is in this
bringing america together uniting our
people
united in our nation and i ask every
american to join me
in this cause with unity we can do great
things important things bringing
america together biden said uniting our
people
uniting our nation to which we said as
we watched it and we meant it when we
did
amen unity that is precisely what this
country needs more than it needs
anything we are all in this together
every single
american and we have no choice but to
hang together
let's finally accept that we are one
country and act like we are
and make this a better place for
everyone unity
no decent person opposes that if joe
biden can bring unity
to this country he'll be a legitimately
great president
but there's a catch there always is a
catch we're going to bring america
together joe biden told us today
but not everyone is going to be included
unity doesn't mean
every single american because not
everyone who was born within our borders
really is an american some of us are
beyond the pale of citizenship
morally we may have american passports
and birth certificates but effectively
we are hostile foreigners we are the
enemy we must be defeated
here's who joe biden says those people
are
a rise of political extremism white
supremacy
domestic terrorism that we must confront
and we will defeat we will defeat
political extremists domestic terrorists
white supremacists those are america's
enemies we must
wage war against them we must quote
defeat those people
that's what biden said today it seemed
like a highly significant part of his
speech and maybe a significant part of
the democratic party's governing agenda
going forward
we're not imagining this we weren't the
only ones who noticed it
people who voted for joe biden heard it
too watch
i heard a declaration of war against
white supremacy
and against the lies that brought our
democracy
to the brink and president-elect biden
will inherit an unprecedented
domestic security crisis
a declaration of war against white
supremacy
now you may not have noticed that
because at one level it's not very
remarkable
not many americans support white
supremacy most people in this country
find it disgusting
of course and they should but the
question is what is it
exactly now that we're waging war on
white supremacists can somebody tell us
in very clear language what a white
supremacist
is that's not some picayune semantic
question
joe biden isn't a high school debate
coach joe biden is the new president of
the united states joe biden controls the
largest military and largest law
enforcement agencies
in the world he has now declared war so
we should know specifically and
precisely who
exactly he has declared war on we have a
right to know that
innocent people could be hurt in this
war they usually are
there could be collateral damage in this
war and the casualties
will be americans so again what is a
white supremacist you might be surprised
to learn just how broad the definition
for that has become
bloomberg news has described a wall
along our southern border as quote a
monument to white supremacy so be
certain not to support that
colin kaepernick who seems to have the
unequivocal support of corporate america
calls the fourth of july an example of
white supremacy
so you'd better put away the fireworks
and the hot dogs the united states army
a trusted institution if there ever was
one has used an entire
manual on what is and what is not white
supremacy
so you should know this among the
telltale signs of a committed white
supremacist are these
celebrating columbus day using the term
american exceptionalism
any support for federal border security
or english only measures or quote
education funding from property taxes
all white supremacy
using the phrase there's only one human
race is white supremacy two
according to the army and of course
voting for donald trump all white
supremacy
here's the problem let's say you don't
buy those definitions
let's say you're for example white but
poor and you have trouble accepting the
idea that you're benefiting from some
kind of structural
advantage you better shut up about it if
you know what's good for you because
according to the united states army the
quote
denial of white privilege is a classic
sign of yes
white supremacy so no complaining
you can see the problem with this we
definitely can see the problem
this show was not on the air for six
months before there was an organized and
highly aggressive campaign
by prominent democrats to denounce us as
white supremacists
the first time it happened the people
who work on this show many of them kids
were shocked and horrified by that white
supremacists
what's worse than that the phrase evokes
images of
burning crosses and lynchings it's awful
in our case it was totally undeserved
this show
is completely opposed to the practice of
judging people on the basis of their
skin color
we have said that repeatedly every week
for four years
no show in all media has said it more or
meant it more sincerely
why have we said that why are we opposed
to judging people on the basis of their
race
not simply because we were taught to
oppose doing that though we were
but because it's immoral and it's
immoral because we believe in god
that's the real answer believing in god
doesn't make you a good person
unfortunately but believing in god does
answer the question of where we came
from
god made us that's what believers
believe
once you understand that it is
impossible to think that any one race is
inherently better or worse than any
other race
because god made every person god
assigns identical
moral value to every individual god
cares about all of us
equally so we are judged by what we do
not by how we were born we really
believe that
most americans really believe that it's
not an
accident that martin luther king was a
christian minister
and that joseph stalin and mao zedong
were not
secular leaders are the ones most likely
to count their populations by race
and then to embrace collective
punishment through history they often
have
we've said all of that before in the
show many times
so the question is why have they kept
denouncing us as of all things
white supremacists we thought a lot
about that
you should think a lot about it too now
that the bide administration has
declared war on people they claim
have white supremacist ideas in our case
it all started when we began criticizing
the people in charge
other channels fill their heir with
attacks on so-called proud boys whoever
they are
or the q anon enthusiasts or gun owners
in central pennsylvania who fix air
conditionings for a living and tend to
vote the wrong way
they go after those people and you can
see why attacking those people
isn't hard none of them have real power
they don't let's be honest they don't
but private equity does have power
a lot of power so does google so does
citibank so is the government of china
so does even silly alexandria qazi
cortes with her massive social media
accounts
those are the people who run our country
they don't like to be criticized
on the other hand they don't care to
defend themselves directly with reason
and fact often they can't do that so
instead they denounce
you your critics their critics as white
supremacists
and then they just ignore what you said
fine
we've dealt with this for years we're
used to it no longer hurts our feelings
we understand what's going on
but there's a new regime in power
starting today
and they seem to be planning to
accelerate things dramatically
they're getting the fbi and the pentagon
involved
in this hunt for people who may
criticize them that's a very big
change and you should understand what
it's really about